yeah but these guys are just researching
like what
shampoo photosynthesis for solar panels
all right conditioner shampoo
what a guess
[Music]
so a janitor
kept hearing this noise right he's
working at this
um at this like lab
at the Polytech Institute in New York
and he's like what is this [__] noise
it's beeping and beeping the beeping and
beeping
and so he finally finds this like it's
like a big huge fridge
and he's like oh well I'll just turn it
off
oh there it is got the beep good in
doing that he destroyed over a million
dollars worth of research oh [__] whoa
what was in the fridge [__] like mice
DNA and [__] dude cell cultures samples
and experiments
supposed to be kept at minus 112 degrees
Fahrenheit I thought you did it because
he was like pissed yeah no he just heard
this beep and he's like that's so
[__] annoying trying to do my [__]
he's like trying to listen to Joe Rogan
Charlottesville RFK yeah you're trying
to listen to RFK and Joe Rogan talk
vaccine stuff and his voice is all kind
of like yeah it's really hard yeah we
did something similar like that I was
shooting a sketch with my with our
friend at a sushi restaurant
and the [__] fridge kept making noise
so he unplugged the fridge
for I think like four hours
I don't know how the fish was after but
it was in North Hollywood yeah it was a
sushi restaurant a restaurant that you
guys were just like patrons of no no we
we uh we we shot on a day we were
shooting yeah yeah yeah so we blocked it
we blocked it for four hours they just
wrecked their whole like thing did you
see anything on the news about it after
like like three people died it wasn't my
shoe I was just there just the [__]
rancid fish meat I was just there just
to [__] say some random lines it was
the Ahi Tuna I mean in North Hollywood
fishing North Hall I heard that happens
a lot with servers
with like janitors and servers you know
like the uh the computer server you're
not supposed to just like yank it out oh
yeah oh you just pull the data out it'll
be like vacuuming and then they'll be
turning oh that someone left that thing
on
it's like and then all of it's just [__]
is that what happens at Spectrum [__]
bro I [__] think so the same old lady
that [__] Consuela from Family Guy
yeah and it happens all day electricity
dude yeah I do hey you know what's not
in Vegas Spectrum well it's out there
then I hate them really there's only
like one out there too right like one
main one out there anything is better
than [__] anything I like [__]
though so yeah he um he destroyed all
this research right
um take a million dollars to replicate
the samples oh my God part of research
into photosynthesis to further
development of solar panels was he like
trying to save money for the building
like you guys have an AC too cold I wish
we know enough about photosynthesis
right come on he just said that um it
was it was annoying the the alarm was
annoying
um they had a mechanical malfunction
with the fridge so it was giving uh like
an alarm Target code right to say what's
going on with it and he was just like
this is a [__] I don't even want to
deal with this [__] and also the the
funniest thing is there was no cleaning
required in the area so he was just like
really annoyed by the people from far
away and he had no business even to be
there wow okay yep so he lost his job he
lost his job did he lose his life too
been terminated
they said terminated maybe they killed
him yeah yeah yeah he's dead if he
worked for Bill Gates or some [__] I
feel like he's dead oh yeah this sounds
like uh those are Bill Gates's bile
[__] mosquitoes yeah this sounds like
the beginning of like a a campy horror
comedy where the scientist comes back
and he's like what did you do and he's
like turn it off and he goes
where am I going to get cells now yeah
yeah exactly right well I suppose
there's only one place for me to get
cells now
uh yeah apparently uh there's a lawsuit
now because of this what are they gonna
take from that guy he's got nothing I
mean just Lysol maybe the company that
he works for I think it's that yeah it's
the it's the uh that's good yeah there's
a a report following the incident
claiming the gender believed he had been
turning on the breaker rather than
switching it off so he didn't like just
unplug the fridge like a dumb [__] do
you think that'll hold up in court per
se he turned off the whole breaker yeah
[Music]
thought he was turning it on though
he's just trying to [__] he's like maybe
he'll turn out turn around kind of thing
damn you would think there's like a
padlock on that thing you would think
you couldn't even get in the area bro
yeah but that's what dude like when we
talk about defense contractors and like
all that kind of [__] because I used to
do toner
for like Northrop Grumman and Lockheed
Martin yeah so I would like send text to
these classified buildings and these
guys needed to have like special access
passes and [__] they need to have like
classified Loki card yeah access [__]
just a swap printer toner wow because
they're in these high access area
security yeah well that's probably the
reason why because some [__] jerk off
is gonna you know delete all the files
pull a can and just like or could be
copying the files and send them to
Russia or something yeah yeah yeah sure
that's true yeah but we can't just
delete everything yeah but these guys
are just researching like
what
shampoo photosynthesis for solar panel
all right conditioner shampoo yeah but I
guess but why would you need like high
security you know like you never would
have thought that the janitor would take
their own liberty to turn off the whole
thing yeah that's a bold move has the
janitor ever [__] anything up in here
all these years not that I know of
everything's already [__] up it's
never like [__] on your pillow in
there or something it's the opposite
things get better I know
things get fixed less holes
when they interviewed the gender he says
he didn't think he did anything wrong he
was just trying to help out oh poor guy
I bet because you hear alarm and you're
just trying to turn it off it sucks to
be like Ernest Lee just dumb yeah like
he's a good guy probably but but then
again how much of the blame is on the
[__] company to to make sure that
like this stuff doesn't happen well the
thing is you can't block the [__]
breaker box that's another thing that
like that's in any like
I mean the lab I'm sure the same rules
you have to have like [__] access to
the breaker panel so don't aren't they
supposed to have backup power and just
like fail proof like things to like if
it's that important or also they just
probably didn't think that was ever a
possibility don't we just sound like
those [__] on Twitter who were like
talking about the Titan sub the whole
time yeah like why didn't they just use
a better controller yeah then they
wouldn't have been stuck down there yeah
a better controller would have totally
helped implosion I can't believe you
bought the wrong materials what a
[__] idiot
I think I've seen enough zombie movies
where if you're in a like
High research place that they have their
own generators if anything go bad yeah
if they could do it how come they can
that's true I know the way this guy
solves problem is also weird though
because like if there was smoke in the
hallway and the smoke detector goes off
he just turns off the smoke detector is
that affecting the smell core problem
God the [__] beeps man
it's like a a Newman from Jurassic Park
where he meant to turn it off so someone
could steal something
you never know but his employer is being
sued Daigle cleaning services oh [__]
yeah that's a big oh yeah so he's not
getting a suit his employer is damn
don't they have insurance and stuff yeah
I assume so I'm just answering for them
a million dollars yes they do yeah they
totally do yeah they're covered doesn't
say though
that sounds kind of sad
because he probably just wanted to clean
maybe maybe they're also just like lying
about how much research was in there oh
that's true I would to inflate the
numbers
it was super top secret all they had was
a [__] sub yeah
Coca-Cola or something he had a Jersey
Mike's he's like myself yeah someone
broke into my car like please call him
dude I got like seven Rolexes in there
took all of them I keep them in my car
for safety yeah always I felt I felt so
dumb because I I truly don't have the
guts to [__] lie in those situations
but last time my trunk got broken into
in front of my house they took my
subwoofer and then uh I I called the
cops anyway because I like to [__]
report this [__] so that the stats go up
in the area that it happened yeah yeah
so the cop comes and he's like oh what
did they take I'm like they took my my
subwoofer out of the trunk and he goes
what's the value of the subwoofer I was
like I don't know like 50 bucks and it
goes your subwoofer is only 50 bucks
that's what the cop said I was like yeah
thanks man yeah [__] you dude
okay I gave you an honest value and
that's how you treat me yeah yeah I feel
like [__] wait how did you go yeah what
kind of sub is that all by yourself no
because it's I bought it in a grocery
store parking lot it's such an old
subwoofer from like another car yeah and
it's like an offer up subwoofer that's
probably the real value of it's probably
50 bucks but did you but did you tell
him that like just so you know full
disclosure I'm really good at getting
deals
you gotta factor that in you should have
been like oh you wanted the retail value
see I got the I got the current Blue
Book value if I was good at getting
deals I would be saying a higher number
exactly
thank you